hello and welcome to the shaky science
show where in this video we're going to
take a brief introduction to viruses so
once the world is talking about one
specific virus at the moment I thought
I'd take the opportunity to give just a
more generic overview to what actually
is a virus so let's start with the
definition viruses of sub microscopic
infectious agents that replicates only
inside the living cells of another
organism viruses can affect all types of
life-forms and so this doesn't just mean
animals they can also infect plants and
other microorganisms including bacteria
and archaea and actually the majority of
viruses infects microbes so how many
viruses actually are there
well Faris's are the most abundant
biological entities on the planet but
what about an actual value well one I
could find was 10 to the power of 31
more than I had space to write out so
that is an absolutely huge number and to
put it into some kind of perspective
that means that there are 10 million
times more viruses than there are stars
in the universe so now we've established
that viruses are pretty much about
everywhere what actually makes a virus
well viruses contain certain components
they contain genetic material and so
this can be found in either DNA or RNA
form viruses also have a protein coat
very KZ and some for all viruses have an
outside and flap of lipids so forest is
really are the bare minimum and that's
even reflected in their genetic material
that literally only includes for the
proteins required for the virus to act
and the protein coat protects the virus
and it's otherwise known as a capsid so
when I Ferris is not inside an infected
cell or in the process of infecting a
cell viruses exist in the form of
independent particles often referred to
as fire yawns so whilst all viruses
share these core characteristics they
are hugely diverse and for one example
they come in a variety of shapes so one
that I've drawn out here is a complex
shape and that's the bacteriophage but
there are also lots of other different
shapes such as icosahedral shapes such
as the adenovirus
rod-shaped viruses such as the tobacco
mosaic virus and also spherical shapes
viruses such as the influenza virus and
the influence of virus is actually an
example of a RNA virus and RNA viruses
almost never infect bacteria but they
can infect humans and plants and other
organisms so what are the main questions
regarding viruses is well how do they
spread and so there's a variety of
different mechanisms that viruses can
employ one of which is fear effectors
such as transmission between plants that
can be done via insects there's the
typical coughing and sneezing such as
with the influenza virus
there's also fecal oral routes so that
could come through the transmission also
by like entering the food and water
system and the classic examples are
norovirus and rotavirus and lastly
there's also the sexually transmitted
forms of viruses such as HIV so the last
common question regarding viruses is are
they actually living so many people will
argue either case but if we consider
that viruses carry genetic material they
can reproduce and they can evolve
through natural selection they do have
many characteristics of living organisms
and so I think the best way to think of
this is as I had someone described
viruses or organisms at the edge of life
so hopefully this has provided you with
a brief intro to viruses and as always
thanks listening